[Music]
uh what's up friends welcome back to
culture revenge this is the wisecrack
podcast where we
spread our wings and fly and cough and
pass out through the cultural zeitgeist
i'm your host michael burns joined as
always
by the woman who would rather miss two
days of brushing her teeth than
one day of work serbia um
and our special guest today someone
who's criticized this podcast very
viciously
for quote our embarrassing lack of
narrative continuity
um you know him from show me the meaning
raymond creamer
raven how are you today i wouldn't i
would never
say that about uh our friendly sister
podcast on the uh the wisecrack network
listen i read your yelp reviews it's
fine
um so we have a lot to talk about about
today
including our complicated feelings about
the olympics
um why some people feel bad when they
have to miss work
and how real life disasters can end up
creating
discontinuity in the media that we love
but first
um just wanted to say hi and intro our
friend raymond who's joining us today
you likely know him because you probably
also listen
to show me the meaning if you don't this
is raymond raymond tell us a couple of
facts about yourself just
in case there's any culture binge
listeners who have not met you before
what are what are two important facts
they should know
oh two important facts uh one i am as
you said a co-host of uh
show me the meeting wisecracks movie
podcast and uh
two i'm no alec let's be honest
i i don't have that that that smooth
gravelly voice that we all
we all know and love and certainly by
now we all miss i'm a regular listener
of culture binge
and uh the last few weeks without him no
no shade to the uh the other guest hosts
and certainly no shade on myself
i'm gonna do the best that i can but uh
uh yeah i'm a big fan of the show
uh i'm very very happy to be here and
thank you guys so much for inviting me
on
we're so happy you're here i like to see
you come on show me the meeting
show me the meaning yeah thank you well
so let's not give them too much free
promo because they don't
i know that we exist so okay
let's just do that it's gotta start
somewhere y'all don't acknowledge who he
exists we've had you on the show
multiple times michael all right
you have that's a good point um
well let's get into it let's talk let's
talk something that
is a segment i joked about killing last
episode three weeks ago
and the response was very much don't you
dare and that's slaps and chaps um
so serbia let's start with you what is
slapping and chapping
in your charmed existence this week
so what slaps is um
it's hard to think about what slops at
this point uh i was going to say
um a show i watched but for some reason
i just can't remember what the name of
it
what chaps is that i i had altitude
sickness over the weekend
um but now i'm thinking that maybe it's
not altitude sickness
uh after a conversation here with our
our lovely burns
i think maybe it is uh the c word
um and i went to a family wedding this
weekend
uh despite strong objections i was
forced to attend
and i believe that i i
may have contracted the covid oh i was
i was worried it was cancer oh yeah well
people say the c word that's what it
means that's right
oh no so sorry to anybody i didn't mean
to make light of that
wow really starting off like that um
wait did you give a slap nothing's
laughs
no no when we started the show i had a
slab but then when we did like the
chatting before we went live it and
nothing slaps in this moment because
energy was so negative oh my god i feel
so bad now oh raven how about you
chaps slaps uh anything that actually
slaps in your life or is it just a
negative vortex
well it's one of those things where we
could all be like hey kovet you're on
notice you chap this week
um but i i think you all had a pretty
good run of doing slaps only podcasts a
while back just to
put some positivity out there so i'll do
i'll do a couple slap snow chaps
um one is a uh a local slap if you live
in los angeles there's a phenomenal taco
stand that's called
angels tijuana tacos so good you've been
there
so gonna love that place okay so i
i had passed their taco stand near me
there's a few spread out across los
angeles and the line is quite literally
no exaggeration around the block
every every single time i passed this
place and i kept making a mental note i
got to check them out i got to check
them out
finally i do and it's the best burrito
i've ever had
best burrito i've ever had al pastor
chunks of pineapple beans and rice a few
salsas on there to give a little bit of
heat
and as long time listeners know i'm a
big time burrito boy
and this was absolutely the best
the best one that i have ever had i've
gone there like three or four times
since i think i've had it once a week
since
then and it is it's the difference
between like
you know oh yeah i could go for a
burrito no i could go for an
angels two on a tacos uh al pastor
burrito i crave this [ __ ] thing
so what i need you to do now is go to
tacos el russo
and compare it to their burrito which is
called they call them soba carrots there
um and just do that comparison and then
come back
yeah that's that's that's awesome um was
there another slap you said you had as
well
yeah yeah if you if you aren't local to
los angeles i wanted to uh
to throw something out for um the
unwashed masses who don't live
uh in our wow um no there's a there's a
wonderful series that just concluded on
sb nation called chosen
uh which is about the history of the
cleveland cavaliers culminating in their
uh their championship victory
uh with lebron james i'm not a big
sports fan
but sb nation does videos uh constantly
that are just like deep dives on sports
statistics and just really
weird stories they they also did like a
four and a half hour documentary called
the history of the seattle mariners that
came out i think last year
it was really really good and uh they
they had one documentary called fighting
in the age of loneliness
which is about um kind of like the rise
of
mma and in uh in popular culture
as it sort of uh intersects with like
increasing atomization in american
culture
i can't recommend their work highly
enough they do phenomenal stuff even if
you're not a sports fan
like myself i can't tell you the last
time i watched a basketball game it's
still really really fascinating how they
do these deep dives
into into the history of sports
that uh draw greater themes
out of like the surrounding history the
political and social context of the time
as well so
highly recommend uh that their their
newest feature is uh chosen about lebron
james it's really really good
and it's available on youtube for free
oh so
go wherever you live just get the best
burrito that you have local access to
and then watch that um or listen to it
however you want to do it
okay my uh slaps and chaps slaps um
we're kind of late on this since we've
been
three weeks removed now and now this is
old news but uh
the season two of i think you should
leave is great if you haven't watched it
um
watch that and then another thing i
watched which i've avoided for a while
and finally binged all of was mythic
quest
and oh boy i wish i would have watched
that sooner um
fantastic show it's on apple plus it's
uh rob
mcelhaney and charlie day and megan gans
all of the it's always sunny in
philadelphia team
um created this show and it's about um a
team
that runs a uh or a games company
that that makes one of the most popular
role-playing games in their fictional
universe
and it's so good and it's such a diverse
and fun cast
and it's both really really funny really
heartwarming certain times and it's the
only show i've ever seen that made
a covet acknowledging episode that was
good and they did like a remote episode
in season two that kind of acknowledged
covid and working through covid and they
did a really good job of it so
um you know if you have apple plus t if
you have their subscription service to
watch
ted lasso just use it to watch
mythicquest 2
i would say um both seasons are are up
there
um my chap someone told me i couldn't
say this but i'm going to
my chat is that since we were last
together i got covered
and for anyone who's wondering yes i got
vaccinated
um but i did uh attend a concert that
turned into a little bit of a uh
a super spreader event and most people
who were there
got it and it sucks and i'm still
getting over it
and you know i'll just i'll be a nerd
about it and say
get vaccinated if you haven't because
this sucks ass and if you are vaccinated
and you're in a place where it's
spreading right now just like be careful
and don't go to crowded concerts um
where everyone's unmasked
and singing and and yelling and people
are just doing things that involve the
exhalation of their breath
just don't do it it's not worth it um
don't go to family weddings either
well that's just like a never go to
weddings ever
but definitely don't go to family
weddings right now i'm so worried too
sir because i i'm having a wedding in a
few months and we thought
by this point things would be like
mellowed and now it's like oh no we're
probably [ __ ]
um but you're mandating vaccines aren't
you
i'm like putting a it's gonna i'm sorry
no no you didn't say that and if anyone
is listening in my
my stupid family don't come if you're
not vaccinated idiots
but uh yeah we're gonna put a thing on
the the the invite that's like please be
vaccinated and then i'm putting a little
thing on
the wedding website that's gonna have a
note about that as well which i feel
okay about
um i do too i wish that was how it was
at this wedding i found out that there
were unvaccinated guests there
that's not good yeah and i think i'm
going to recommend we might even just
like
casually recommend but not like enforced
people just like hey get a rapid test
the week before why not
um so you just said you heard of that um
there was a baby shower i heard of where
they
they had uh everybody had to to give a
negative test and masks were required as
well during the event even if you were
vaccinated
there you go um well let's get into it
we got a bunch of topics to get through
and as much as i'd like to complain
about how much being sick sucks
um you know i'll do it another time so
something we talked about on the last
episode
um you know we were pre-olympics at that
point and we discussed shikari
richardson and some of the
very not cool stuff the olympic
committee was doing in terms of
uh banning certain athletes for very sus
reasons
i wanted to zoom out a little bit this
week now that the olympics are in full
force
and and kind of ask the question should
the olympics
exist um
okay so serbia will be taking the
counterpoint on this one
yes i i imagine what we're heading
towards is one of those scenarios
where where you two are diametrically
opposed and i do the annoying thing of
saying
i completely understand both of your
positions um
because this is one where i do kind of
obnoxiously exist in that paradoxical
space but
let's talk about the olympics in general
and this is not the first time an
olympics
has happened we're leading up to it and
seemed like everything was a [ __ ] show
like the same thing you know for before
the brazil olympics leading up to that
um stadiums were still under
construction people had died
in the in the like rush construction
projects there was like zika cases
breaking out everywhere um in sochi
um things weren't finished they didn't
have snow in a bunch of the venues um
there's a bad history of things going
really poorly
in a city before host the olympics um
also and there was a good
washington post thing about this from
last week um
the olympics always loses money for the
host city um just from a simple like
financial standpoint
um they always go over budget they
always lose money and i didn't know this
until recently
one of the things that keeps cities
putting bids in
um is is like construction lobbyist
because it's such a huge financial boom
for local the local construction
industry
that it's often construction lobbyists
that are the ones that are pushing for
it
um but in this particular olympics in
tokyo japan which has been pushed back a
full year already
you know a lot of extra bad things are
happening
so in the weeks leading up to it japan
went into a full state of emergency
um because of the the kova 19.
super low vaccination rates in japan um
when when the game started it was in
like the single digits
um you know we've already talked about a
lot of the really unfair
disqualifications leading up to it but
one thing that's happened is some really
good athletes are unable to be there
because of contracting kovid so like
american tennis player coco goff is one
of those people
um another thing that's gone down this
week is that the heat and humidity have
been horrific
and the olympic committee in tokyo like
lied when they were pitching it and
there's a document you can read where
they talk about how great the weather is
this time of year in tokyo but like it
never is
and athletes are like getting sick and
passing out already because of how hot
and humid it's been
um we've seen a lot of things involving
athletes mental health uh most recently
it was a pretty huge story yesterday
that simone biles had to
first drop out of the u.s women's
gymnastics teen competition has now
dropped out of all individual events as
well and this is the person who's sort
of
um like the face of the u.s olympic
team at large someone you know is in all
the ads was in all the promos the
the expectations have been huge and i
would say a
very shocking performance yesterday
after that happened by michael
phelps as a commentator on the olympics
former
swimming best swimmer ever guy um
gave some really articulate thoughts on
like the intensity of the the mental
health toll faced by these athletes
which i thought was really cool and
glad to see uh that getting talked about
on tv um
but then to zoom out a little more um
when the olympics happened this has
happened in
tokyo it happens everywhere people end
up losing their homes
um there's actually there was one story
in japan where a couple of women have
had their homes moved now during two
different olympics i think it was like
the 64 tokyo olympics and now the 2021
um because of eminent domain and
construction the city basically like
moved their house also in bigger cities
with with
big unhoused populations those people
get very screwed over when the olympics
come to town
um so so there's a lot of bad
things that accompany the olympics i
know um los
angeles is supposed to host in 2028 and
um you know there's already the the
la um you know no olympics campaign i
think that's what it's called
um well yeah with a bunch of organizers
and writers and activists are fighting
against the city hosting it so
it's a weird thing right because i'm
someone who who likes
sports i like watching anything that's
competitive
but i can't not acknowledge the reality
of all of these things
um now obviously one of the solutions is
like don't have the olympics anymore
another one that's been posed a lot
which i think is a really good solution
is just have consistent host cities
so rather than like rebuilding new
cities every four years
four years there's one city that always
has a summer olympics one that always
has the winter olympics or maybe you
know one city that does both
um so all that is bad
i'll say two things that i thought of
then and then i want to hear what you
guys think about this um
two things that i thought had been very
cool about the olympics this time
are uh skateboarding and surfing
internet which is super cool and if you
would have asked 12 year old me
if skateboarding and surfing ever would
have been in the olympics he would have
said no way bro
um but it's been very cool to watch that
especially cool
like in women's skateboarding street two
of the three medalists were 13 years old
so that's very rad to watch uh
incredibly talented young women
when medals at 13 because i could barely
win at b plus
in like math class at 13. is that is 13
i didn't know
how how young can you be in the i
thought there was like a an eight
i think there's no age i thought that i
was 15.
but i thought there had been a bunch of
gymnasts who had been disqualified
because they were too young
for uh for competition in previous games
i mean i may be misremembering that but
no that's true maybe it's different for
different events
and maybe it's by sport too and i'll be
honest
i don't see the point of that i think if
you have like a really ball or six year
old just [ __ ] put him on the court
like
yeah are you afraid yeah like what
you're gonna disqualify him because they
might beat you that's more
more impressive to me yeah but before i
ask you guys if you think about this you
know it's it's worth noting that
there was so much media coverage about
why the olympics probably shouldn't
happen leading up to it a lot of
coverage about all that stuff but as
soon as it starts
it's and this happens every time the
entire media narrative shifts
except for you know more like alt
publications towards like
this is great here's the inspiring story
and like i don't know i get caught up in
that sometimes um
so i know how i feel about this is
objectively i think
the olympics probably shouldn't exist
subjectively
and you know there's people who even
even just because of
the shikari rich and richardson
disqualification know there's people who
are like we shouldn't watch it we should
boycott the olympics blah blah
i like don't have that in me i've been
watching it on television i'm interested
in some of the things and then part of
me feels like well
just because the structural thing sucks
so bad doesn't mean i'm not going to
like
um support and appreciate some of these
athletes who are not famous and who only
have this thing to do you know
um on this stage every four years but
it's still hard to exist in that tension
so
so what do you guys think about the
olympics like
should they exist can we watch them with
a clean conscience are we bad for
enjoying them
um raymond you're our guest we'll let
you get started before serbia
eviscerates you
i don't i mean i don't have the
strongest feelings about this as like a
an emotional or you know competitive
experience
i i haven't been watching the olympics
the only time that any of these stories
break through to me is
like the simone biles thing that
happened recently uh the shikari
richardson thing when
when stuff like that comes out where it
is
legitimately a pretty big story because
it calls into question
like the validity of of the olympics as
you know as an institution i'm not
necessarily opposed to the olympics
existing i just
i i think they could be you know way
less corrupt about it
and also way more chill about it maybe
if
if yeah if they would just you know kind
of live and let live but that's
you guys discussed this on on the last
episode of the podcast that
you know the the olympics are not the
only overly punitive
uh institution with regards to like you
know drug use or whatever um
so i i think a lot of that stuff is
endemic to the culture but
there there's still there's still an
aspect of it for me
where if you if you told me tomorrow oh
they're never doing the olympics again
i just kind of shrugged my shoulders i
wouldn't be dancing on its grave or
anything if that helps soften the blow
for you serbia i think if people if
people really enjoy this and it inspires
them
uh to you know uh take up a new sport in
their own life or just to have role
models to look up to i totally
understand that
um but you come back to those those
stories michael about how people are
displaced
how uh they the olympics have this
weird habit of just economically
ravaging whatever city hosts
them um and then in addition to that
it just all seems like
what the olympics are supposed to
represent this notion of
you know solidarity and uh and and
familyhood around the this one shared
activity or this one shared gathering
i think a lot of that just comes off as
disingenuous when
you you look at uh i don't know how the
sausage gets made for lack of a better
phrase
um so yeah i mean if you dig the
olympics
whatever i i get it um but i also
i also just feel like god do we have to
have like fifa levels of corruption
going into this thing and and i i
remember reading something a while back
that
i think beijing is the only city to have
uh uh not to to
have been able to like actually benefit
from having the olympics because they
they made all of their uh stadiums and
stuff much more utilitarian and they
they actually put in the design these
plans to like
turn them into municipal spaces and
things like that once the olympics were
over and uh
in reading in that same article about
how so many other cities they
they now just have these like dead
vacant you know decaying monuments to
yeah this this one thing that happened
like eight years ago or 12 years ago
or whatever and i i don't know when i
when i think about all of that it just
makes me feel like god there's got to be
a better way to do this like when they
do the world cup you know they
obviously i just mentioned how corrupt
fifa is but at least they
they do try to make an effort to like oh
we're going to host this game in this
stadium that already exists for this
major league
club or whatever but i i don't know i
just think there's got to be a better
way to do these things that can
that that can still give olympics fans
what they want
uh and give olympics critics some some
kind of a fig leaf
you know that they're they're cleaning
up their act a little bit but uh i don't
know what do you think serbia
i agree with you i think i love the
olympics i mentioned on our last episode
that i take time off work
um guilt-free i was curious it was that
true
that you i mean do you just watch
olympics coverage around the clock then
i just not around the clock but like
throughout the day like i'll be like ooh
swimming's on or like oh it's equestrian
time
um equestrian time
i just love the olympics i love the idea
of like
um just global athletes like everybody
coming together and it makes the world
feel so much smaller because
other than like the world cup and things
like that i can't think of anything else
that like brings everybody together and
so i like that idea a lot um but i also
agree i i get really upset when i think
about the
uh economic the detrimental economic
effects that it has on the local economy
um and the effects that it has on the
people
and crime increases and things like that
like i remember
reading about how horrible it is for a
host country
and so that bothers me i like the idea
of there being
a stable location for winter and summer
or at least like
maybe a pool of like five and it just
like rotates
um i think that could be interesting i
i wouldn't want the olympics to end but
i agree that there could be
there could be major improvements made
and maybe we can
it would be great if we didn't have so
much corruption um
i would really like that less corruption
would be great
i think we can all agree less corruption
would be awesome
um yeah it is funny with all right
anti-corruption stance on culture yes
kohl's revenge
if we have one thing we agree on it's
the corruption not good
you're first yeah it is funny like this
happens every time i watch the olympics
where like i will be
so caught up in some sport or event
as if it only exists every four years
wouldn't it totally exist in other times
but i would have
no interest like if you just like this
morning
i was watching archer archery and i was
like
genuinely interested in it if it wasn't
the olympics and archery was on tv
what is this like people [ __ ] larping
as robin hood i don't need to watch this
um but then when it's you know
nationalistic all of a sudden it's like
okay yeah yeah
even like you know swimming last night
watching katie ledecky's historic win in
the 1500 freestyle
um it's just like this feels so big but
like
she does this all the time they always
have swim meets i never would want to
watch the other one so it's
it is a very interesting thing of like
the the nationalistic part of it making
our brains get into it which is
either cool because it's like serbia
said everyone comes together and we like
it or it's weird
because we're like yes our country needs
to win
but like all of these like trials and
things like you mentioned like it
happens throughout the year
the the country's all still it's all the
same competitors so
um i watch like ice skating and um
some of those other events throughout
the year and you see the same people
they're doing the same routines they do
all year long so it's just on a
bigger stage at the olympics um
yes i mean i guess i just i just think
it's fun
i like hearing the stories i like seeing
the olympic village
i'm like such a sucker for that stuff
what's your what's your favorite event
sherby
okay so for winter olympics i really
like for someone to ask
just hoping i was gonna send a message
on telegram please ask me
um so for winter olympics i like skating
so
all skating events uh short track
speed skating ice skating ice dancing i
also really love biathlon um
cross-country skiing
um i like uh moguls
and for summer olympics
i like the equestrian i like
uh gymnastics um swimming is nice too
but i'm not so i'm not into it as much
this year um
i'm not as big of a summer olympics fan
so i just
sort of like watch to see what's what's
going on
did you know that one of the american
equestrian athletes is bruce
springsteen's daughter
really oh really jessica springsteen and
i was like oh it's funny that's like her
name but it's like no it's like legit
bruce springsteen's daughter is an
olympic wow equestrian person although
my thing with that is like give the
horses medals
that's not real um yeah i don't know i
think it's nice to see the springsteens
get a win but
yeah yeah you know i worry about that
family uh
looking at horses no that is cool i just
wish the horses got the medals or they
there was some like determinant
reward for the horse where i think it
makes the horse's life bad because i
read there was some article about all
the horses
that they have to fly around the world
and horses can't like fly in
they can't they can't find that they're
getting altitude sickness going to
horse weddings you know they they have
all of it
never i'm don't get me started on horse
weddings the worst
um okay so we fixed the olympics we
figured out how everyone should feel
about them
um no but of course let us know what you
think
about the olympics we'll see how they
they turn out we'll definitely
in a couple weeks we can we can check in
again on
the end of the olympics and how
everything went
um but in the meantime serbia
very curious to hear your thoughts on
this you are going to talk with us this
week
about how some people and not
me my friends not me feel guilty for
taking time
off work i mean this one hits me because
i just had to take
all last week off of work because of
this covid and i'm still kind of at half
speed so i've been thinking about this
so
talk to us about people taking time off
work
yeah um so i've been thinking about this
a lot because i haven't been taking a
ton of time off work but i did take some
time off this last
week to attend this family wedding and
i didn't feel guilty but i felt
pressured
a bit um so my team is super
understaffed right now so if i'm not
there then there's no one
to do the work and i also have a new
manager
and um
about a year ago so prior to a year ago
i felt a lot of pressure
to continue to work even when i was off
i would check in i would look at my
messages
i would have to attend calls because my
manager at the time would ask me to
and i only stopped doing it about a year
ago when i had a new manager and she
set an expectation that i was to
completely disconnect from work
and it also helped seeing
my european counterparts absolutely
disconnect from work they
most of them take off all of august
um and they're they're just not around
like you could ping them but like
nobody's answering
um they put like really funny out of
office
uh auto responders on their email where
they'll be like
i am not coming back until september 1st
so that was really nice to see like a
difference in
um expectations when it comes to
to paid time off and
i'm curious um
[Music]
i was curious how other people felt
about it so i talked to a few friends
about how they feel
and my american friends they said yes i
feel guilty or i feel stressed i feel
pressured
i've been asked to attend calls just
like i had
um and my european friends have all said
no
i i don't i just tell them i'm taking
all of august off and i had a call with
a friend from spain who said i
told my manager i'm taking all of august
off and
uh if he needs to you know terminate me
upon my return i completely understand
but i'm
i'm taking all of august off uh and my
friends from asia were like no i i feel
very stressed out taking time off um so
it's interesting to see the cultural
differences
and what i've realized throughout my
career
um is that and if you don't know this
this is a
big news flash uh work doesn't care
about you your company doesn't care
about you
so you have to be your your strongest
advocate in every way
and that includes taking time off and
setting boundaries with
your time because nobody will value it
as much as you do
and the one thing that i that makes the
biggest difference
is your manager um my previous manager
was fantastic and saying
please disconnect completely i don't
want you to see you online at all
the one before that asked me to join
calls and
i've noticed that when
my manager asks me where i'm going or
what i'm doing during my time off
i feel stressed about it like i feel
stressed saying
oh nothing like i'm just gonna take a
week off and
hang out at home and go to the beach or
go you know walk around or go for a hike
and there's like this pressure to almost
say like i'm going to be out of town or
i'm going to be camping or
something that makes me sound like i
will not be available
um and i wish that that my manager
or like any manager like wouldn't ask if
you don't have that type of relationship
because i think it can
cause undue stress on on others and i
don't know if this is specific to me
or if just based on my own experiences
with managers
um because i remember one christmas my
my manager asked me what i was doing
um i had taken two weeks off and she
asked if i was going anywhere
if i was doing anything and i said no i
have some a lot of family coming into
town
uh the second week but the first week
i'm just gonna do my own thing
and uh she put me on call to work
that that first week since i wasn't
going anywhere and i would have access
to the internet
uh so i think that has shaped me to
to try to be to seem like i'm gonna be
disconnected a lot of times
i don't know how do you two feel do you
feel guilty or pressured to be around do
you
also get stressed when somebody your
manager or somebody asks you when
uh what you're doing when you take time
off
i mean i i don't think i've ever felt
guilty but i've definitely felt
pressured
um and honestly like until last week
it's like the first time i've taken off
work in a while
and when you have kova and you're sick
it's like easy and was almost but then
it like it made me feel weird that like
being sick people are just like oh of
course of course of course
but there's been other times where i
i've tried to take time off
literally i mean honestly like because
of like stuff that's borderline mental
health stuff just like needing to take
some time off and not be around
and that's so much harder um and it
feels
weird because i think i've had times at
work before where i do
want to take time off almost just like
for myself
but you can't say that or it feels weird
saying that or whatever it might be
um and i do think there's the pressure
these days
especially in a lot of like you know
tech oriented or media oriented jobs
that you should just always be around
and i think even like when we're not on
vacation
you know a lot of us look at our
messages
around the clock or whatever like our
work messaging platform is if you have
it on your phone
our brain treats it like you do twitter
or instagram or whatever so you get you
know you catch yourself looking at it
um but yeah but i think this is like an
important thing was american work
culture i think is toxic as [ __ ]
um when i when i worked in the uk i
remember i was shocked when i had like
an hr meeting when i started this job
and i was at a university and i had like
seven
weeks of of paid leave a year and
they were like very adamant with me that
like i had to take it
they were like you know sometimes we
have we we have people that like don't
take all their seven weeks off and i was
like
what and they were like and just so you
know like once you're off like you need
to set an out of office email
you can't be on campus like it was weird
to have a job where someone was talking
to me about how important it was to take
my time off
which i then did just glowingly and
happily
but it is a thing where i feel sometimes
i don't do a good enough job
of taking time off unapologetically
not making excuses not offering to be
around via email not offering to jump on
meetings
and you know whatever we do for work it
often feels really important but unless
you're like
a [ __ ] medical researcher or an
emergency room doctor
nothing any of us do is that important
um
but i still struggle with it raymond how
about how about you what's your attitude
towards this stuff
um i'm probably not the best person to
ask about that because i don't have like
a
formal sort of structured work
environment in in the way that a lot of
folks might
um you know yeah i mainly work as a
screenwriter
so for me it's just kind of like i i
write when i have an assignment i do my
best to meet deadlines
and then i write for myself on spec just
to
try and stay sharp but i don't know i i
don't
i don't have like paid time off or
whatever i just have to
try and stretch the money i make as far
as i can um yeah
so that's even with like stuff like that
it's hard too because then there's that
pressure to like
when you do when you're not working or
you know i think for people that have
worked freelance before
it's that weird thing where if you're
not
pitching or you're not getting freelance
work well then you're not getting paid
so it's that tension of like do i take
time off
or do i continually try to find more
gigs or whatever
do you ever register have you ever felt
that uh
yes no i mean it's not at this point
that's more like my manager's problem um
but well that sounded ungenerous he he
like he has his money he's like i love
him but
um you know i i don't know for for the
past 10 years i've also worked as a
camera specialist at a a
warehouse for uh grip and lighting
equipment but
even even that is like i just kind of
make my own hours i just go in and work
with the gear and
um you know i clock in when i have some
free time
and stay as long as i want to and i
clock out when i'm finished
um so yeah i i don't know i mean
i just like i said i i hear i hear
both of you and i think i'm i'm pretty
much in the same league i
i know that i i could never really
thrive in like a
an office environment or a corporate
environment or a place in which
people are like expecting me to care
about
this job even when i'm not on the clock
or whatever like that's
that's the kind of thing that's i also
don't understand the notion of like
a rigid 40-hour schedule just in general
because in my mind
if if someone works for 20 hours you're
extracting
20 hours of labor for them and you're
paying them for 20 hours of labor who
who cares if they don't come in for
another 20 hours
just it like that that stuff is just
it's very it's very very difficult for
me to grasp that concept of like
of the the the inherent value of
productivity
like i i just don't i just don't really
get that like
if you have x amount of hours worth of
work to do
how does it matter the degree to which
that that amount is partitioned i
i just don't understand that um
but like i said i'm i'm a terrible
person to ask about this
i haven't had a real job in a decade
yeah
no but i feel like raymond like
especially in the context of living in
in los angeles
and doing creative adjacent work i mean
this is
like this is the first time in my life
in the past
what year and a half that i've truly had
a more like traditional
you know full-time work schedule job
and you know before that i was i was
just doing like freelance
uh writing and other stuff and before
that was in academia which is very
flexible all things considered schedule
wise and i've even felt it recently
being in los angeles like you know a lot
of my friends do uh
have schedules and jobs that are more
flexible and i get so mad sometimes
because it seems like they do get to do
more fun stuff than me
um and i do think there's like a
attention sometimes between
in in the current economy between like
people that don't have to have like a
traditional job and even like seeing on
some job contracts
when they when they like put in like 10
paid days off a year my brain goes like
that's [ __ ]
it all [ __ ] year and you're giving
people 10 goddamn days
um to live life like that sounds
horrible it makes me want to
never mind i won't say it's too dark but
my sister
my sister just had her second kid and
she just started a new job
where they were like oh and this is you
know she was telling me it's way better
than my last job i get like
i used to have you know four paid days
over seven paid days off she's like now
i have ten i got like a full three more
and she's like i'm gonna have to burn
all those
with you know my daughter uh but like
no no matt leave or [ __ ] like that i
mean it just [ __ ] sucks like it
i mean it is there there is as both of
you have mentioned there's this very
weird
i don't necessarily know that it's 100
tied into like the hustle or grind
culture of instagram i think that is
sort of its own beast
but there is that that sort of like
corporate fealty culture that permeates
a lot of office spaces at least in the
popular imagination i think
mm-hmm yeah it's interesting though that
this is like a topic that is discussed
at a lot of tech companies and a lot of
startups in general and now people are
companies are instituting minimum
[Music]
vacation policies for example you have
to take 30 days off a year you have to
take three weeks off a year
um i'm not sure how they enforce that
but it's nice i think to set that
that standard and that baseline
expectation for people that
that you are encouraged to take 30 days
off
a year um at least and
i've seen some companies a friend of
mine works at a company
and they um shut down the whole the
whole place
one day a month and it's just for
everybody to recharge
and i think it's nice that you that we
have
that that's like a trend that's coming
to sort of normalize
um time off especially in uh
for american workplaces because we only
get 10 days off mostly
um yeah hopefully it becomes a bigger
trend and more accepted and normalized
yeah i think the other side of that
though especially as
more and more folks start working from
home through the pandemic and even
a lot of businesses are signaling now
that that may be
kind of you know the new normal so to
speak
uh going forward that a lot of their
workforce if they can work from home
will be allowed to do so and
i think that's i think that's a net
positive personally
but i also can see how um
you know trends that have already been
established of work encroaching on
people's personal lives could
sort of be exacerbated by that that you
know
because you work from home now there is
no there is no start and end time at
least not in a in a clearly defined
sense that
you may be expected to work like
maybe the expectation is that you're
still putting in the same amount of
hours each day but it might
it might be in the middle of the night
all of a sudden um you know it might
just be spread out
in ways that become their own kind of
anxiety inducing like i said i think
more people working from home isn't that
positive but
i can i can still see how it it could
kind of accelerate some of those uh
uh some of those trends of the workplace
invading the home space
yeah i i'm the idiot that has done that
multiple times in my life where i have
like work from home stuff and it's like
oh i can just like do this whenever
and then i waste my whole day
procrastinating and i have to spend my
entire night working and it sucks so bad
um
but i think what we can all agree on and
anyone who's listening here you know
um i think the main thing we can all
agree on is you shouldn't feel guilty
for taking time off work your work isn't
your life
like serbia said your job does not give
a [ __ ] about you
one day they'll find a reason why they
don't need to pay for you anymore and
your ass will be out the door
and you'll think like why did i ever
sacrifice any of my finite time on earth
for these people um it's hard to realize
that because
and work can foster these relationships
where we feel a sense of guilt and we're
on a team
and it's our family we had to do stuff
but like nothing you do
matters right nothing we do at our jobs
truly matters
unless you unless you're like a fire
person i don't know or like
a chef that makes really good videos
there's i don't know
i'm gonna draw the line no jobs matter
i think there are definitely some jobs
that truly matter but i i mean
i can't claim to be one of them i'm
being very hyperbolic no no no no i know
it
yeah but you know you you know if your
job
is is is world changingly important in
how it matters so let's
be realistic about what we do but take
time off don't feel guilty
and definitely at least get the minimum
you have
whatever your amount of vacation days
and sick days are
take those every year at least that and
then [ __ ] take more
i worked it up negotiate like if you get
a new offer and they give you two weeks
negotiate for another week of vacation
uh i was just gonna say i worked i
worked at a video store when i was a
teenager
and there was one there's this old guy
who came in one time and tried to steal
two dvds
and the you know the things beeped on
his way out and i i
i went out and snagged him i said hey
man i'm i don't want to cause any
trouble we just you know we just want
our videos back no big deal
and then my manager came out to say like
oh what's the ruckus and i said it's not
a big deal he's just you know
he he forgot to pay for a couple videos
but he's gonna go on his way and they're
like no
we're gonna call the security we're
gonna get the you know
this this will not stand both i was like
this is this old guy who wanted to watch
rose red on dvd
like so i'm i'm sitting there thinking
to myself like [ __ ] me this is just
this this is what i signed up i don't
want this guy to go like
get a even even if it's just a slap on
the wrist like it's not worth it
like so after that i mean uh
the lesson left the floodgates the
floodgates were open i just let people
steal yeah
but i i bring that up only to say that
like
yeah there there is a bottom line that
they're looking out for and you are not
included in that equation listen this
has long been a pro
uh petty theft podcast and
especially especially if you're right i
do have an
update on whole food stealing um that
i've had it confirmed the they have an
employee non-confrontation policy
so you have you have nothing to lose but
you're changed friends
if you are at a whole foods go to that
self-checkout
and just fake scan a few things toss
some stuff in your bag
they're not going to confront you and do
it in such a way or if you need to
you'll be like oh my god i'm sorry i'm
just so out of it i was just like
scanning stuff did i
oh my god i didn't i didn't scan that 30
dollar stake
i'm silly like that and i'm curious if
uh
if we could actually get the how-to for
stealing from whole foods up here in
a bullet-pointed list in case uh in case
you're watching listen
there's a back episode i won't say which
one where we basically did that so
go back through the culture range
archive and you're awesome today we're
talking about hot wiring
i don't know if it's yeah we did that it
was more survey
yeah you seem like a little bit more of
a rule follower survey
yeah yeah because i'm so afraid that i'm
going to get in trouble
i would do no you won't stress no no
policies
um okay well before before we go we got
we got to talk about something else um
and we're so excited as we said before
to have raymond here it's always good to
have
a guest in to have a new perspective you
know i
i know what i'm going to say serbia is
what she's going to say i know what
serbia's going to say serbia knows what
i'm going to say but we don't know
what raymond's going to say about
anything so you're going to talk with us
about
discontinuous narratives if i understand
this correctly so
yeah tell us what you're thinking and
we'll chat about it
well i was um i was recently reading a
lot of i read a lot of climate change
coverage and there's a climate scientist
named
i think it was alex steffen uh who has
been writing a lot in his newsletter
recently uh al or excuse me sorry for
calling you out
michael um you mentioned on a previous
episode
uh uh emily atkins uh wonderful
newsletter he did
uh if you're a fan of that newsletter
alex stefan also writes a great
newsletter you can check him out on
twitter
but he's been writing about this concept
of discontinuity a lot lately this
notion that we don't
we don't really know what planet we live
on anymore and it's hard for us to make
any kind of
assumptions or generalizations about
this planet because
everything is like everything is off the
table it's just
you know we're not sure what planet this
is it's just not the earth that we were
born on to
and i've kind of been thinking about
that notion as it applies to
my particular areas of interest uh with
regards to
film and television media in general and
i've noticed a lot of like
sort of i don't want to say like
flagrant discontinuity
in our our narratives now but it is kind
of
interesting to see how um i don't know
if y'all are aware of this but
uh back in the west wing days um
that show which was on air during 9 11
9 11 just didn't happen in the universe
of the show
and aaron sorkin who i have an eternal
axe to grind with
just found new reasons to make all of
his characters like
really racist and islamophobic um
and uh i've noticed this in like
for example the the reboot of gossip
girl that's on hbo max now in the very
first episode
they kind of pay some lip service to
kovid as
like when the kids are getting together
one of them says like oh that's what
your face looks like behind that mask
and
there's there's another student or maybe
it's one of the teachers who says
something to the effect of you know
after a year of teaching on zoom this
will be a breath of fresh air so
whatever it was there's just like a
couple of lines that feel
extremely squeezed in there that you
know
were not part of the show's original
conception because i'm sure the show has
been in development long before
covet 19 was um you know throwing
everyone's plans out of whack
and i just kind of i i kind of seized on
that because
while they acknowledge kovit exist
exists or existed within their world
it is like a decidedly post-pandemic uh
universe in which the show takes place
and
i just find that kind of grimly
fascinating just
that the way i was describing it to uh
maddie the
the culture binge producer before we got
on air um
was that there there has always been
this sort of
burden of escapism that's put on our
fantasy films you know whether
it be marvel or star wars what have you
because those exist in
decidedly individual universes
but it's just kind of weird to me as as
people start to produce new content
um how it seems as though the
the sort of decision that people are
making collectively is that now
dramas comedies teen soap operas on hbo
max
all of those things will also have to
kind of like shoulder this burden of
escapism
and that any movie regardless of genre
at this point although i'm sure
you know there have already been a
handful of interesting movies made that
directly confront the pandemic and
in the surrounding circumstances thereof
but it is
it is just kind of weird to me to think
about like and you know
get too heavy but we're getting to a
point where like the real world
is so grim that even like the most human
of all of our stories at least as
typified by genre examples are now
having to
sort of willfully ignore uh the
the you know sober reality in which they
would otherwise take place
and i'm just kind of curious where y'all
see this heading maybe
uh you you're not uh always
thinking about movies and tv or whatever
maybe maybe that's more of a me thing
but i'm curious if there are things
in your lives or that you've experienced
that you think are kind of like
the the typical narrative or
circumstances under which you would
consume that media
or uh even like you said serbia going to
family events and stuff like that
the notion of having to just kind of
like ignore this elephant in the room
and how will culture continue to evolve
or is the notion at this point that
as you kind of said so eloquently in
your last um or one of your last videos
on bo burnham's inside michael that
are we just kind of like rearranging the
deck chairs and
how many people are going to openly
acknowledge that
yeah it's so weird and you know it i
think the thing i think about a lot is
like how much
is is media and especially like audio
visual art
a matter of escapism
and and like a certain version of like
comfort food
and how much of it is art that we expect
to
confront the material the material and
psychological conditions of our current
moment
and and like think through things with
us or
or confront things about the world
and i know that a lot of my favorite
cinema especially
does that like says things about the
world or tries to think through
things about the actual world um
but it's just a hard balance i mean i
feel like sometimes these days
it ends up being and like and i and i
don't know this this genre super well i
know you do raymond but
sometimes it feels like it ends up being
like
weird like horror films and stuff end up
being the only ones that are
like sort of metaphorically or sort of
like allegorically dealing with things
that are actually happening in the world
and how bad it is
because we can't deal with it otherwise
or you know in the 90s when we were
you know when sort of like climate
change was becoming a bigger part of the
national
narrative you know we had this whole
string of like end of the world disaster
movies
but we rarely have movies that imagine
like what the world
will probably actually look like in 30
years and more of like a grim
realist way and i wonder
you know i'd love to be in the room with
someone trying to like
sell a movie or a tv show that
deals with with reality maybe a more
realist way but
yeah i don't know and the covet thing
especially i think with like climate
stuff
i get mad that there's not more art that
deals with that
with covet i think part of me initially
was like i don't want to think about
this anymore so i
hope things don't make i think we've
talked about this on here before like
covet episodes
or whatever because like why do i want
to live in that world anymore
but then i think like you know how how
could a show do that interestingly
i think like that's like i mentioned
this in my slap like the show mythic
quest i thought
did a really good job of that and in
particular the reason they did a good
job of it is because their covet episode
dealt with how
the mental health ramifications of
loneliness and isolation are very real
and you have a character in that show
who it's not that the character gets
sick with covet i think we all know like
that's
that's a very real straightforward
uh negative effect of of getting sick
like that but we see someone kind of
break down because they're just like
alone
and they're working on their computer
all day doing tech stuff
and and we see that isolation and
alienation hit and i thought they did
that very beautifully but
yeah i don't really know sir what do you
think about this i like escapism i watch
film and television to escape from what
i'm going through in my daily life
like i don't want to be reminded of the
pandemic when i'm watching it tv
um so it bothers me
like either commit to it or don't and i
watched
a show um work in mom's
i started watching just to have
something while i work sometimes
um and then the latest season
they showed uh the characters like
looking at their phone
and seeing like a message that that the
country was locking down but then that
was it that was there was like no other
mention
of the pandemic there was no nothing it
was just like
march we get a text message that the
country's locking down and then it
fast forwards to august and so like
things like that bother me
um so i feel like just just either do it
or don't do it
um but i prefer they don't do it uh so
i think i think there's enough going on
like i don't need to see it and i don't
need to process things
unless it's in a way that like burns
said like where they're dealing with the
unique aspect
of the situation i think would be
interesting to see like a story to tell
that isn't that isn't the most
well-known story or the most prevalent
story
um so i think that would be nice i think
there was something else you mentioned
raymond but i can't really remember
about
um about like daily life like how things
have changed and
ignoring the elephant in the room and
when i was at this family wedding it did
seem like
like nobody was really talking about the
pandemic like nobody was talking about
stuff and
i felt like i was i was the only one
talking about stuff
like because i was wearing my mask and
um
but like it was strange to think that
like
that the way that i looked at the way i
look at film and television was the way
that people looked at
at this family event like let's just i'm
i'm here to escape i'm not here to think
about the pandemic even though we're at
a large
family gathering and nobody's wearing
masks and a lot of these events are
indoors
um so it was it was interesting to see
how people
want it to turn off and then when they
go back to their daily life they'll go
back to wearing their masks
in restaurants or in uh um
grocery stores and things sure yeah i
i think the thing that was just kind of
i i agree with you serbia that it's kind
of like do it or don't do it
and that was the thing that jumped out
at me so much about the gossip girl
example was like
okay you acknowledge that this thing is
real but then they have decided to just
forego any ripple effects of that all
the characters lives are
totally unaffected either economically
or you know just physically they they
they come back into a school that is
completely
you know it's it's just the school
like there's you know there aren't
partitions everywhere there are no
lingering effects or knock-on effects of
the pandemic
and i think that's the uh i agree with
you if you want to make a tv show go and
make a tv show
i i think audiences are savvy enough to
know that uh
uh drama is fiction or you know
tv shows are fiction rather um but it is
just
it's just it's just weird it's weird to
to acknowledge like and i think gossip
girl is an interesting
example because the the original run of
the show
much like i don't know downton abbey was
another big nighttime soap from that era
that seemed like kind of a response to
the recession
in a weird way where it was like oh yeah
people
people have had this massive life change
and a lot of people are on their back
their back foot financially a lot of
people's lives have been ruined
and folks just want to watch like you
know pretty people in pretty places
and living in the lap of luxury and
there's just this weird kind of
uh you know to to bring it back to the
reboot the like
there there's a weird kind of mirror
example happening with this where it's
like no
folks now just want to like the height
of fantasy
has become not like dungeons and dragons
and wizards and witches the height of
fantasy now is just having a life that
is unimpeded by
these sort of you know accelerating
disasters and stuff and i just
i find that very weird but then the
obverse of that is like those weird
hotel commercials
where families uh wearing masks are like
giddy checking into their room and
jumping on the bed and stuff and it
looks like something out of a paul
verhoeven movie
um so i yeah i don't really know how to
circle the square
michael what you mentioned before about
movies that
confront uh dystopian realities or
environments in a realistic way children
of men i think is the perfect example
of like a distressingly realistic
depiction
of of a dystopic world um
where everything is just kind of
normalized and all like
the horrors of of everyday life are just
kind of like
folded into the background noise of that
universe in a way that's
that's just kind of like it you know it
sucks it sucks to to read about
to bring it back to the olympics it
sucks to read about like oh yeah coveted
cases are ballooning and we're just
going to keep on swimming
like it's just it's just one of those
things where it is kind of
it is kind of shocking the degree to
which folks are forced into this notion
of
like well we have no choice but to
normalize this and accommodate this and
just welcome it as
essentially the the background noise of
our you know
increasingly deteriorating existence but
yeah on a lighter note
you know it's uh it's good tv i guess oh
my god
well we do we do that don't wind down
but oh sorry sorry
go ahead you never
yeah i was going to say as we wind down
i loved i think serbia's
original point something like either do
it or don't do it and i think that's
yeah absolutely
uh a helpful way to think about this and
i think some i definitely agree with
um now of course our opinions matter but
your opinions matter
a lot maybe even more um so
let us know you think about the topics
we talked about today or other stuff you
want to talk about
by shooting us an email at culturebinge
at wisecrack
dot co just know m's take the m's out
culture binge wisecrack.co
or you can call us at 213-534-8807 that
is 213-534-8807 going to dive into the
mailbag deeply today we've been off for
a few weeks some of the topics aren't as
relevant anymore but
please hit us up for next time in the
meantime i will say this we got
a comment from our good friend dude
abides today where he said
my question of the week you are given
six hundred dollars for retail therapy
what are you buying so i'm going to ask
that to raymond and serbia right now
dude by its question you get six hundred
dollars
you have to spend it on something that's
in the category of retail therapy
what are you doing with it um so
there are two things um i would buy one
would be
a really nice pan or like like a skillet
or a really nice pot
um i really want like a nice cast iron
one
so i would buy something like that uh
the other thing i would buy
there's this uh this like skincare
company that i heard about i think it's
called skinceuticals
um and uh it's very expensive
like everything is like 150 i would buy
something like that so that i could look
young forever hell yeah not that you
need to look young forever
but hell yeah um raymond what would you
buy with your 600
of retail therapy money i hate to be
super boring but i don't
i i don't have many splurge items i'm a
big big movie collector so i'd probably
uh go crazy at the barnes noble
criterion sale uh maybe pick up a few
books while i'm there and uh
i could use a new pair of flip-flops i
guess
wow a simple man of simple pleasures you
love to see it folks
huh i think i would maybe want to spend
some money on some like nice
speakers for my my like tv audio system
situation
i was thinking about that the other day
when i was watching a movie and i was
like
my audio's a little spotty i wish it was
better so maybe like a sono system or
something like that so i could have some
speakers behind me or on the sides or
something like that would be pretty cool
um that or like like really nice
towels it'd be nice to get out of the
shower or the bath and just have a
really nice towel
like a towel that feels fancy because
like i think i have towels that are
just the whatever i bought that was like
the cheapest thing at target for the
past 10 years is like what i buy for
cows so
i went on a nice towel i used to tell at
my girlfriend's place recently i was
like
[ __ ] me where did you get this it was so
nice
i didn't know they could be that
absorbent because i've been using the
like bottom of the rack ones from target
as well
right and then you know in the chat two
divides did say hashtag buy serbie pot
so you know sir sir we lives in a legal
state so luckily she can buy her own pot
if she needs to
um but if you you know if you do want to
listeners send
uh drugs in the mail just do it try to
you know just
serbia at uh i don't know i'm
i'm not gonna make up a fake address
it's not worth my mental effort because
it's waning
um so before we wrap up um
if people wanna rather than just email
us at culturebridgewisetrack.com or call
us at two on three five three four eight
zero seven they just wanna bug you on
social media how can they do that
raymond we'll start with you where are
you at on social media
yeah you can find me on twitter and
letterboxed i'm at crematoria
um if you're uh if you're a big movie
fan come by say hi we can always talk
movies uh
or whatever you know hell yeah do that
and of course everyone listened to
raymond on show i probably should have
plugged this
i know i got you no no it's better than
you didn't come in here and plug your
own [ __ ] i'll do it i'm a company man
um serbia how about you where can we
find you on the internet you can tweet
me at siripatel22
awesome and i'm uh michaelo burns on
twitter and instagram
um we'll be back soon maybe we're back
next week
maybe we're not i think we're doing next
week yeah so we're
making up for time off we'll be back
next week um oh we have a very another
fun special guest
um so come back and see us then it's
only week from now there's been culture
binge
for raymond and serbia i'm michael see
you next time
[Music]
you